I was excited to go playing is excited
to go playing with bumper because he
hadn't played there in a long time
either Bubba's in the top five he's got
two green jackets hope that okay
he's amazing look my ball is up on the
green now you just attack it right no
pressure no thoughts no that's not what
we want right there he's a professional
golfer and he's also a professional ball
breaker I can't hit a shot without
talking in my backswing or saying
something negative to me I'm like what
what is this let me hit one more we
don't get to say cut here we got to just
keep going
bub and talk to all that the Pelican
hair all that everywhere you start
hitting like a man yeah little chubby
right now go ahead and swing it like a
man off the tee let me get you in the
box okay right here we need this
up-and-down man all right don't be
nervous don't shake it oh really man
heckling doesn't help my game my fault
thank you
I forgot you need words of encouragement
I need you to heckle the other players
we got heckle the other guys I need your
help